while the theme of last September and
October was tank for two of the Dolphins
ultimately didn't tanked but they still
got to it despite plenty of speculation
that they would go Justin Herbert the
organ quarterback will maybe go in a
different direction altogether the
Dolphins undeterred by the health
concerns relating to the Alabama
quarterback three lower body injuries
and three seasons a broken hip that
marred his final year at Alabama the
Dolphins don't care they have their
quarterback of the future he also may be
the quarterback of the present but while
they still have Ryan Fitzpatrick if they
want to they can give to a time to get
up to speed so instead of moving up to
number one to get Joe Barrow the
Dolphins get to a tongue to buy low at
number five they keep their two
additional first-round picks and they
can put some more pieces in place around
Toa and we'll see when talking about
lower can do at the NFL level
specifically will it be healthy and then
we be effective for more videos
throughout the night on the first night
at the 2020 NFL Draft stick around
you'll hear more from us all night long
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports